[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at five o'clock ed Lewis washed up
tossed on his hat and coat got his car
out and headed across town towards his
TV sales store he was tired his back and
shoulders ached from digging dirt out of
the basement and wheeling it into the
backyard but for a 40 year old man he'd
done okay Janet could get a new vase
with the money it saved and he liked the
idea of repairing the foundations
himself
it was getting dark the Setting Sun cast
long Ray's over the scurrying commuters
tired in grim-faced women loaded down
with bundles and packages of students
swarming home from the University
mixing with clerks and businessman and
drabs secretaries he stopped his pack
art for a red light and then started up
again the store had been open without
him he arrived just in time to spell the
help for dinner go over the records of
the day maybe even the clothes a couple
of sales himself he drove slowly past
the small square of green in the center
of the street the town park there were
no parking places in front of Loyce TV
sales and service he cursed under his
breath and swung the car in a u-turn
again he passed the little square of the
green with its lonely drinking fountain
and bench and single lamppost from the
lamppost something was hanging
a shapeless dark bundle swinging a
little with the wind like a dummy of
some sort Louis rolled down his window
and peered out what the hell was it a
spy of some kind
sometimes the Chamber of Commerce put up
displays in the square again he made a
u-turn and brought his car around he
passed the park and concentrated on the
dark bundle it wasn't a dummy and if it
was a display it was a strange kind the
hackles on his neck rolls and he
swallowed uneasily sweats slid out on
his face and hands it was a body a human
body look at it boys snapped come on out
here Don Ferguson came slowly out of the
store buttoning his pinstripe coat with
dignity this is a big deal it can't just
leave the guys standing there see it it
pointed into the gathering gloom the
lamppost shuttered up against the sky
the post and the bundles swinging from
it well there it is how long has it been
there his voice rose excitedly what's
wrong with everybody that they just walk
on past don't Ferguson lit a cigarette
slowly ah take it easy old man there
must be a good reason or it wouldn't be
there
I've reason what kind of reason
Ferguson shrugged well like the time the
Traffic Safety Council put that wrecked
Buick there some sort of civic thing how
would I know
Jack Potter from the shoe shop joined
them what's up boys there's a body
hanging from the lamppost voice said I'm
gonna call the cops why they must know
about it god I said I realize it
wouldn't be there
I gotta get back in Ferguson headed back
into the store business before pleasure
boys began to get hysterical you see it
you see hang in there a man's body a
dead man sure ed ER
I saw it this afternoon then I went for
coffee you mean it's been there all
afternoon sure what's the matter
Potter glanced at his watch after run
see ya later ed Potter hurried off
joining the flow of people moving along
the sidewalk men and women passing by
the park a few guards stuff curiously
the dark bundle and then went on nobody
stopped nobody paid any attention I'm
going nuts
Louis whispered he made his way to the
curb and crossed out into the traffic
among the cars horns honk Tangra the at
him he gained the curb and stepped up
into the little square of green the man
had been middle-aged his clothing was
ripped and torn a gray suit splashed and
caked with dried mud a stranger Louis
had never seen it before not a local man
his face was partly turned away and in
the gentle evening wind he spun a little
turning silently his skin was gouged and
cut red gashes deep scratches of
congealed blood a pair of steel rimmed
glasses hung from one ear dangling
foolishly his eyes bulged his mouth was
opened tongue thick and ugly blue Oh for
heaven's sake Louis muttered sickened he
pushed down his nausia and made his way
back to the sidewalk he was shaking all
over with revulsion and fear why who was
the man why was he hanging there what
did it mean
didn't ya why didn't anyone notice he
bumped into a small man hurrying along
the sidewalk watch it
the man grated oh it's you Edie nodded
dozit Lee hello Jenkins what's the
matter the station we clerk court heads
armed he looks sick the body there in
the park Jenkins led him into the alcove
of Loyce TV sales and service take it
easy Margot Henderson from the jewelry
store joined them something wrong it's
not feeling well
Louis yanked himself free how can you
stand here don't you see if it God's
sakes what's he talking about Margaret
asked nervously the body had shouted the
body hanging there more people collected
is he sick his head voice you ok it the
body boy screamed struggling to get past
them hands caught at him he tore loose
let me go at the police get the police
Edie better can the doctor he must be
sick more drunk voice fought his way
through the people he stumbled in half
fell through a blur he saw rows of faces
curious concerned anxious men and women
halted to see what the disturbance was
he fought past them towards his store he
could see Ferguson inside talking to a
man showing him an emerson TV set peep
foley in the back of the service counter
setting up a new Philco louis shouted at
them frantically his voice was lost in
the roar of traffic and the murmuring
around him do something he screamed
don't stand there do something
something's wrong something's happened
things are going on the crowd melted
respectfully for the two heavyset cops
moving efficiently toward Loyce
name a cop with a notebook murmured
voice he mopped his forehead wearily
Edward C voice listen to me back there
address the [ __ ] demanded the police car
moved swiftly through traffic shooting
amongst the cars and buses Louis sag
against the seat exhausted and confused
he took a deep shattering breath one
three six eight Hurst road that's here
in Pikeville that's right
Louis pulled himself up with a violent
effort listen to me
back there in the square hanging from
the lamppost where were you today a cop
behind the wheel demanded but where
Louis echoed you weren't in your shop
were you no he shook his head no I was I
was home down in the basement in the
basement digging an a new foundation
getting out the dirt to pour cement
frame what why what is that to do with
was anybody else down there with you
know my wife was downtown my kids were
at school
Louis looked from one heavyset cop to
the other hope flickered across his face
wild hope you mean because I was down
there I missed the explanation I didn't
get in on it like like everybody else
after a pause the cop with a notebook
said yes that's right you missed the
explanation then it's official the body
it's supposed to be hanging there it's
supposed to be hanging there for
everybody to see
headless screamed weakly Oh what good
lord well I guess I sort of went off the
deep end
that's all maybe something had happened
you know something like the here Ku Klux
Klan some kind of violence communists or
fascists taking over he wiped his face
with his breast pocket handkerchief his
hands shaking
I'm glad to know it's on the level it's
on the level the police car was getting
near the Hall of Justice
the Sun had set the streets were gloomy
and dark the light had not yet come on
oh I feel better
all I said I was pretty excited there
for a minute I guess I got all stirred
up now that I understand there's there's
no need to take me in is there two cops
said nothing well should be back in my
store that the boys haven't had dinner
I'm all right now
no more trouble is there any need of
this won't take long
the cop behind the wheel interrupted a
short process only a few minutes a bit
sure nice muttered a car slowed down for
a stoplight I guess I sort of disturbed
the peace funny getting excited like
that and glassy and the door open
[Applause]
you spoiled out onto the street roll to
his feet castle moving all around and
gaining speed as the light changed voice
leapt onto the curb and raced among the
people burying into the swarming crowds
behind him he heard sounds snouts people
running they weren't cops he'd realized
that right away he knew every cop in
Pikeville a man couldn't own a store
operate a business in a small town for
25 years without getting to know all the
cops there weren't cops and there hadn't
been any explanation Potter Ferguson
Jenkins none of them knew why it was
there they didn't know and they didn't
care that was the strange part
Laurie stucked into a hardware store he
raced toward the back past the start of
clerks and customers into the shipping
room and through the back door he
tripped over a garbage can and ran up a
flight of concrete steps he climbed over
a fence and jumped down to the other
side gasping and panting there was no
sound behind him he got away
he was at the entrance of an alley dark
and strewn with boards and ruined boxes
and tires he can see the street to the
far end a street light wavered and came
on men and women stores neon signs cars
and to his right the police station he
was close terribly close past the
loading platform of a grocery store Rose
the white concrete side of the Hall of
Justice barred windows the police
antenna a great concrete wall rising up
in the darkness a bad place for him to
be there he was too close yet to keep
moving get further away from them then
Louis moved cautiously down the alley
beyond the police station was the City
Hall the old-fashioned yellow structure
of wood and gilded brass and broad
cement steps he could see the endless
rows of offices dark windows the setters
and beds of flowers on each side of the
entrance and something else above the
city hall was a patch of darkness a cone
of boom denser than the surrounding
night a prism of black that spread out
and was lost into the sky innocent good
god he could hear something something
that made him struggle frantically to
close his ears his mind to shut out the
sound a buzzing a distant muted hum like
a great swarm of bees
Louis gazed up rigid with horror the
splotch of darkness hanging over the
city hall darkness so thick it seemed
almost solid in the vortex something
moved pickering shapes things descending
from the sky pausing momentarily above
the city hall fluttering over it in a
dense swarm and then dropping silently
onto the roof shapes
fluttering shapes from the sky from the
crack of darkness that hung above him he
was seeing them for a long time Lewis
watched crouched behind the sagging
fence in the pool of scummy water they
were landing
coming down in groups landing on the
roof of the City Hall and disappearing
inside they had wings like giant insects
of some kind they flew and fluttered and
came to rest and then crawled crab
fashion sideways across the roof and
into the building
he was sickened and fascinated cold
night wind blew around a man he
shuddered he was tired dazed with shock
on the front steps of the City Hall were
men standing here and their groups of
men coming out of the building and
halting for a moment before going on
were there more of them it didn't seem
possible what he saw descending from the
black chasm one men they were alien from
some other world some other dimension
sliding through this slit to this break
in the shell of the universe entering
through the gap winged insects from
another realm of being on the steps of
the City Hall a group of men broke up a
few move toward a waiting car one of the
remaining shapes started to re-enter the
City Hall it changed its mind and turned
to follow the others noise closed his
eyes in horror his senses reeled he hung
on tight clutching at the sagging fence
the shape the mane shape had abruptly
fluttered up and flapped after the
others it flew to the sidewalk and came
to rest among them pseudo men imitation
men insects with the ability to disguise
themselves as men like other insects
familiar to earth protective coloration
mimicry
nice pulled himself away he got slowly
to his feet it was night the alley was
totally dark but maybe they could see in
the dark
maybe darkness made them difference to
them he left the alley cautiously and
moved out onto the street
men and women flowed past but not so
many now at the bus stop stood waiting
groups a huge bus lumbered along the
streets its lights flashing in the
evening gloom
Louis moved forward he pushed his way
among those waiting and when the bus
halted he boarded it and took a seat in
the rear by the door a moment later the
bus moved into life and rumbled down the
street
Louis relaxed a little he studied the
people around him
doubled tired faces people going home
from work quite ordinary faces none of
them paid any attention to him all sat
quietly sunk down in their seats
jiggling with the motion of the bus the
man sitting next to him unfolded a
newspaper he began to read the sports
section his lips moving an ordinary man
blue suit tie a businessman or a
Salesman on his way home to his wife and
family across the aisle a young woman
perhaps twenty dark eyes and hair a
package on her lap nylons and heels red
coat and white angora sweater gazing
absently ahead of her a high-school boy
in jeans and black jacket a great triple
chained woman with an immense shopping
bag loaded with packages and parcels a
thick face dim with weariness ordinary
people the kind that rode the bus every
evening going home to their families to
dinner going home with their minds dead
controlled filmed over with the mask of
an alien being that had appeared and
taken possession of them their town
their lives himself to accept that he
happened to be deep in his cellar
instead of in the store somehow he had
been overlooked they had missed him
their control wasn't perfect foolproof
maybe there were others hope flickered
in noise they weren't omnipotent they
had made a mistake not God control of
him their net their field of control had
passed over him he
emerge from his cellar as he had gone
down apparently their power zone was
limited a few seats down the aisle
a man was watching him Louis broke off
his chain thought a slender man with
dark hair and a small mustache
well-dressed brown suit and shiny shoes
a book between his small hands
he was watching Lewis studying him
intently he quickly turned away Louis
tensed one of them or another they had
missed the man was watching him again
small dark eyes alive and clever shrewd
a man too shrewd for them or one of the
things itself an alien insect from
beyond the bus halted an elderly man got
on slowly and dropped his token into the
box he moved down the aisle and took a
seat opposite Louis the elderly man
caught a sharp eyed man's gaze for a
split second something passed between
them a look rich with meaning Louis got
to his feet the bus was moving he ran to
the door one step down into the well he
act the emergency door release Hey the
driver shouted jamming on the brakes
what the hell Louis squirmed through the
bus was slowing down houses on all sides
a residential district lawns and tall
apartment buildings behind him the
bright-eyed man had lept up the elderly
man was also on his feet too they were
coming after him Chloe sleept
he hit the pavement with terrific force
and rolled against the curb pain lapped
over in pain a vast tide of blackness
desperately he fought it off he
struggled to his knees and then slipped
down again the bus had stopped people
were getting off louis groped around his
fingers closed over something a rock
the call to speak grunting with pain
shape loomed before him a man
the bright-eyed man with the book Louis
kicked the man gasped and fell Louis
brought the rock down the man screamed
and tried to roll away stop for God's
sakes listen he struck again radius
crunching sound the man's voice cut off
and dissolved in bubbling royal moist
scrambled up and back the others were
there now all around him he ran
awkwardly down the sidewalk up a
driveway none of them followed him they
had stopped and were bending over the
inert body of the man with the book the
bright-eyed man who had come after him
had he made a mistake it was too late to
worry about that he had to get out away
from them out of Pikeville beyond the
cracks of darkness the rent between
their world and his
[Music]
Abid Janet Lewis backed away nervously
what is it what ed Lewis slammed the
door behind him and came into the living
room pull down the shades spike Janet
moved toward the window but do as I say
who else is here besides you nobody just
the twins they're upstairs in their room
well what's happened you look so strange
why are you home
edy locked the front door he prowled
around the house into the kitchen from
the drawer under the sink he slid out
the big butcher knife and ran his finger
along it sharp plenty sharp he returned
to the living room listen to me he said
I don't have much time they know I
escaped and they'll be looking for me
escaped janice face twisted with
bewilderment and fear
who the town has been taken over they're
in control I've got it pretty well
figured out they started at the top at
the city hall and Police Department what
they did with the real humans they are
you talking about with being invaded
from some other universe some other
dimension they're insects mimicry and
more power to control minds your mind my
mind
their entrances here in Pikeville
they've taken over all here
the whole town except me were up against
an incredibly powerful enemy but they
have their limitations that's our hope
that they're limited they can make
mistakes
Janet shook her head I don't understand
ed you must be insane insane no just
they're lucky it hadn't been down in the
basement I'd be like all the rest yeah
Louis appeared out of the window but I
can't stand here talking get your coat
I can't we're getting out of here
out of Pikeville we've got to get help
fight this thing they can be beaten
they're not infallible it's it's gonna
be close but we may make it if we hurry
come on he grabbed her arm roughly get
your coat and call the twins we're all
leaving don't stop to pack there's no
time for that white-faced his wife moved
toward the closet and got down
where are we going ed pulled open the
desk drawer and spilled the contents out
onto the floor he grabbed up a road map
and spread it open they'll have the
highway covered of course but there's a
back road to Oak Grove ah I got onto it
once it's practically abandoned maybe
they'll forget about it the old Ranch
Road good good lord it's completely
closed nobody's supposed to drive over
it I know ed thrust the map grimly into
his coat that's our best chance now cool
down the twins and let's get going
your car is full of gas isn't it Janet
was dazed but her Chevy I had it filled
up yesterday afternoon Janet moved
towards the stairs Edie I call the twins
Edie unlocked the front door and peered
out nothing stirred no sign of life all
right so far come on downstairs
Janet called in a wavering voice we
going out for a while now
Tommy's voice game hurry up it barked
get down here both here
Tommy appeared at the top of the stairs
I was doing my homework we're starting
fractions
Miss Parker says if we don't get this
done you can forget about fractions it
grabbed his son as he came down the
stairs and propelled him towards the
door where's Jim he's coming
Jim's started slowly down the stairs
what's up dad we're going for a ride a
ride where Edie turned to Janet we'll
leave the lights on and the TV set go
turn it on he pushed it towards the set
so they think wist was still he heard
the bus and dropped instantly the long
butcher knife out sickened he saw it
coming down the stairs at him wings a
blur of motion as it aimed itself it
still bore a vague resemblance to Jilly
it was small a baby one a brief glimpse
the thing hurtling at him cold multi
lensed in human eyes wings body still
clothed in yellow t-shirt and jeans the
mimic outline still stamped on it
strange half tournament embody as it
reached him what was it doing a stinger
noise stabbed wildly at it he retreated
buzzing frantically voice rolled and
cruel toward the door Tommy and Janet
stood still the statues
faces blank watching without expression
Oh is stabbed again this time the knife
connected the thing shrieked and
faltered it bounced against the wall and
fluttered down something that to his
mind a war of force energy and alien
mind probing into him he was suddenly
paralyzed the mind entered his own
touching against him briefly shockingly
and utter alien presence settling over
him and then it flickered out as the
thing collapsed in a broken heap on the
rug
it was dead he turned it over with his
foot it was an insect to fly of some
kind yellow t-shirt jeans his son Jimmy
he closed his mind tight it was too late
to think about that savagely he scooped
up his knife and headed towards the door
Janet
Tommy stood stone still neither of them
moving the car was out he'd never get
through they'll be waiting for him it
was ten miles on foot ten long miles
over rough ground gullies and open
fields and Hills of uncut
forests he'd have to go alone Lois
opened the door for a brief second II
look back at his wife and son then he
slammed the door behind him and raced
down the porch steps a moment later he
was on his way hurrying swiftly through
the darkness towards the edge of town
the early morning sunlight was blinding
Lois halted gasping for breath swaying
back and forth swept round down into his
eyes his clothing was torn shredded by
the brush and thorns through which he
had crawled ten miles on his hands and
knees crawling creeping through the
night his shoes were mud caked he was
scratched and limping utterly exhausted
but ahead of him they Oak Grove he took
a deep breath and started down the hill
twice he stumbled and fell picking
himself up and trudging on his ears rang
everything receded and wavered but he
was there he'd got out away from
Pikeville a farmer in a field gaped at
him from house a young woman watched in
wonder
Louis reached the world and turned onto
it ahead of him was a gasoline station
and driving a couple of trucks some
chickens pecking in the dirt a dog tied
with a string the white-clad attendant
watched suspiciously as it dragged
himself up to the station thank God
he caught hold of the wall I didn't
think I was gonna make it they followed
me most of the way I could hear them
buzzing buzzing and flitting around
behind me what happened the attendant
demanded you a new wreck hold up those
shook his head wearily but if they had
the whole town the city hall and the
police station they hung a man from a
lamppost that was the first thing I saw
that they've got all the roads blocked
I saw them hovering over the cars coming
in at about 4:00 this morning I thought
beyond him and he went right away and I
could feel them leave and then the Sun
came up the attendant licked his lips
Navas lee your ally ahead I better get a
doctor get me into Oak Grove Lois gasped
he sank down on the gravel we've got to
get started clearing them out gotta get
started right away
they kept a tape recorder going all the
time he talked when he had finished the
Commissioner snapped off the record and
got to his feet he stood for a moment
deep in thought finally he got out his
cigarettes and lit up slowly a frown on
his beefy face you don't believe me
lawyer said the Commissioner offered him
a cigarette
Louis pushed him patiently away well
suit yourself
the commissioner moved over to the
window and stood for a time looking out
at the town of Oak Grove
I believe you he said abruptly noise
sagged oh thank god
so you got away the commissioner shook
his head you were down in your cellar
instead of at work a freak chance
one-in-a-million noise sipped some of
the black coffee they had brought him I
have a theory he murmured what is it
about him who they are they take over
one area at a time starting at the top
the highest level of authority working
down from there and a widening circle
when they're firmly in control they go
on to the next town the spread slowly
gradually for the very gradually I think
it's been going on for a long time a
long time I don't think it's new why do
you say that how's the kid a picture
they showed us in Bible leader a
religious picture an old print the enemy
gods defeated by Jehovah Moloch
Beelzebub Moab Arlen Ashtaroth so they
were all represented by figures those
looked up at the commissioner Beelzebub
was represented as a giant fly
the Commissioner grunted and I will
struggle
they've been defeated the Bible is an
account of their defeats they make gains
but finally they defeated why defeated
they can't get everyone they didn't get
me and they never got the Hebrews the
Hebrews carried the message to the whole
world the realization of their danger
the two men on the bus I think they
understood had escaped like I did he
clenched his fists killed one of them I
made a mistake I was afraid to take a
chance the commissioner nodded yes they
undoubtedly had escaped as you did freak
accidents but the rest of the town was
firmly in control he turned from the
window
well mr. voice you seem to have figured
everything out well not everything
the hanging man the dead man hanging
from the lamppost I don't understand
that
why why did they deliberately hang him
there that would seem simple the
Commissioner smiled faintly bait
though is stiffened his heart stopped
beating bait
what do you mean to draw you out make
you declare yourself so they'd know who
was under control and who had escaped
Louis recoiled with horror then then
they expected failures they they
anticipated he broke off they were ready
with a trap and you showed yourself you
reacted you made yourself known
the Commissioner abruptly moved towards
the door come along Lewis
there's a lot to do we must get moving
there's no time to waste
voice started slowly to his feet numbed
and the man who was the man I never saw
him before he he wasn't a local man he
was a stranger all muddy and dirty his
face cut slashed there was a strange
look on the commissioners face as he
answered maybe he said softly he'll
understand that too come along with me
mr. Louis he held the door open his eyes
gleaming Louis caught a glimpse of the
street in front of the police station
policeman a platform of some sort a
telephone pole and a rope right this way
the Commissioner said smiling coldly as
the Sun set the vice-president of the
Oak Grove Merchants Bank came up out of
the vault through the heavy time locks
put on his hat and coat and hurried
outside onto the sidewalk only a few
people were there
hurrying home to dinner good night
said locking the door after him good
night
Clarence Mason murmured he started along
the street towards the car he was tired
he'd been working all day down in the
vault examining the layout of the safety
deposit boxes to see if there was room
for another tear he was glad to be
finished at the corner he halted the
streetlights had yet to come on the
street was dim mayor everything was
vague he looked around and froze from
the telephone pole in front of the
police station
something large shapeless hung he moved
a little with the wind what the hell was
it Mason approached it warily he wanted
to get home him he was tired and hungry
he thought of his wife his kids a hot
meal at the dinner table but there was
something about the dark bundled
something ominous and ugly the light was
bad he couldn't tell what it was it drew
him on made him move closer for a better
look the shapeless thing made him uneasy
he was frightened by frightened and
fascinated and the strange part was that
nobody else seemed to notice it
let's bring this baby
meanwhile